okay we do have a david pakman show
discussion forum it's not on our website
it is a subreddit and you can find it by
going to david pakman.com slash reddit
which will redirect you to the david
pakman show subreddit on reddit lots of
great discussions happening there
including a story I haven't had time to
get to this week about Julian Assange of
WikiLeaks Fame it has been widely
reported that it is expected that
Ecuador will withdraw asylum for Julian
Assange Julian Assange of WikiLeaks fame
has been holed up in the Ecuadorian
Embassy in London for how many years at
this point I don't even know at a few of
several years and there is every
expectation according to a number of
reports that Ecuador will withdraw that
Asylum and Julian Assange may soon be
arrested I don't know ultimately what
will happen but it is clear that the
status quo cannot persist indefinitely
and we've known that at some point
something was going to have to change we
did learn by the way during the time
that Julian Assange has been holed up in
the Ecuadorian Embassy that there were
numerous connections to Russian meddling
in 2016 Hannity Donald Trump jr. and all
sorts of other stuff and quite frankly I
want to know the full story when it
comes to Julian Assange and WikiLeaks I
don't know if Ecuador withdrawing its
Asylum will expedite us finding out the
full and true story but it is a story I
really want to know more about and of
course Donald Trump loves WikiLeaks so
maybe he can work his magic talk about
Teresa may talk with Queen Elizabeth the
second yeah make sure that Assange gets
a great deal now Trump likes Assange
right but at some point he was really
bad I think I think it depends on the
day of the week yeah I think that that's
basically what it is also from the David
Pakman show subreddit one of our viewers
J 473 says unequivocally Donald Trump
will not be re-elected just thought I
would call it here first and of course I
am not confident about that I think that
actually there is a very good chance
Trump its reelected I believe it is
abundantly clear that because of low
voter turnout in the United States
because of the continued 38 ish percent
approval rating of Donald Trump you
could see Donald Trump re-elected with
only something like 22 percent of the
adult population in the United States
voting for him and I think that it is no
foregone conclusion that Trump doesn't
get a second term Donald Trump will
never run for president Donald Trump
will never win a debate Donald Trump
will never be the Republican nominee
well he never will never be President
I mean noticing a pattern here there is
a pattern other than he didn't win any
of those debates at first one you think
he did I think he did one out of when
that was that when there was 17 other
people on the stage with him yeah okay
join the discussion at david pakman.com
slash re d di t